did you miss this tiny Easter egg in
Ant-Man 3 it might have been hard to see
but it's actually a giant nod to
Scotland's comic history the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has filled with
Easter eggs and little details for comic
book fans to watch out for from one-off
guest characters with big significance
on the illustrative page to lines that
allude to fun favorite storylines these
wink and Nod moments help pay tribute to
things that just can't fully fit on the
big screen Ant-Man and the WASP quanta
Mania is no different in this regard of
course with so much time spent on both
Scott Lang's story and setting up the
rest of phase five you might not notice
all the Easter eggs on your first watch
quantumania is an ambitious movie albeit
one that arguably doesn't necessarily
deliver on all of its promises it's the
first proper introduction of Kang the
Conqueror the first chapter of The mcu's
Phase 5 and the full-on Sci-Fi Odyssey
that brings a whole new universe to the
franchise that's a lot to cover in just
two hours and to many fans it doesn't
pull it all off but there are still some
fun little references for die hard fans
to suss out one Quantum Mania Easter egg
does particularly easy to miss involves
a code for a bridge in Kang's Fortress
more than just a number it's actually a
clever nod to the beginning of
Scotland's journey in the comics during
the Final Act of quantum Mania when the
rebel faction is storming Kang Citadel
they reach a literal impasse from one of
the bridges is retracted a telepathic
Rebel quas is quickly able to read a
nearby soldier's mind and extract the
code
18147 this number might seem innocuous
to many viewers but it actually holds
two different references to the Ant-Man
the first part of the code 181 is a
reference to Avengers 181 the issue in
which Scott Lang first appears the
second part of the code 47 references
the issue in which Scott took on the
actual mantle of Ant-Man Marvel Premiere
47 both issues were published in the
spring of 1979. about a month apart
Scott has been a notable part of the
Marvel Universe ever since the Easter
egg is certainly easy to miss as the
whole Bridge scene flies by in just a
few seconds conceptually it's nice to
reference godzara jins in the third
installment of his journey unfortunately
fans feel that Quantum Mania doesn't
seem committed to moving forward Scott's
narrative in any meaningful way
ouch
in a Reddit thread one user commented
that the movie quote felt less like an
Ant-Man story and more like Marvel
Studios presents the Rick and Morty
feature film the film's writer Jeff
loveness was a writer on the popular
adult swim Sci-Fi series before making
the leap over to the Marvel side of
things love nurse is also sets offender
script for 2025's Avengers the Kang
Dynasty which has many fans greatly
concerned to be sure quantumania has a
number of things in common with Rick and
Morty including its goofy alien
character designs and constant quipping
holy
that guy looks like broccoli
regardless of how you feel about that
style of humor there's no doubt in fans
Minds that quantumania could have felt
more like an Ant-Man movie although
Scott Lang is still the protagonist he
doesn't get the kind of Arc you might
expect at this stage in his narrative a
common consensus is that his
relationships with his daughter Cassie
and girlfriend hope are scattered and
underdeveloped he barely gets to
interact with his mentor Hank Pym and
references his traumatic experiences in
Avengers end game are played mostly for
Laughs making reference to Scott's comic
book origin story is perfectly fine but
the Easter egg may have done more harm
than good for fans disappointed with the
movie
foreign